I think I'm live on YouTube we had a
little stream episode there little
problem with the flow it's Ustream
alright guys this is gonna be a major
week I'm just gonna wait just a second
because I think there might have been an
alternate stream up we got to get a
couple you guys into the new stream
sorry about the confusion there there is
so much freaking going on and as you
guys know I'm going off the grid on
Thursday no internet no TV no nothing
until September 3rd first off before I
tease the big announcement the beard is
back I know people were freaking out I
accidentally at like 6:00 a.m. with no
lights on in the bathroom I shaved right
before I had clay Travis and and you
know I'm really more beard than man at
this point people were not happy a lot
of upset emails and tweets of messages
on Facebook and Instagram and all that
about the beard the beard is back I'm
thinking about maybe not shaving at all
for all of August we will see about that
ok here we go we got some people in here
this is just a quick teaser for
tomorrow's announcement so I've been
telling you guys for a couple months now
that there are a lot of things cooking
and yes there have been a lot of things
cooking so tomorrow on this channel at
6:30 Eastern 3:30 Pacific we are going
to announce my book title that's right
I've been writing a book for the last
year it was picked up and will be
published by penguin Random House which
is pretty much the the biggest boys in
the business I am super psyched I handed
in my manuscript last about two weeks
ago we have a copy already here I will
unveil a copy of the book the title you
will see who's writing the foreword you
will see the people who've blurbed us
penguin thinks this is going to be one
of the biggest books of 2020 but what
we're doing tomorrow is every single
person that buys the book tomorrow I
will sign a copy for every single one no
matter how many thousand we sell I'm
sure we're going to sell a couple
thousand at least I will sign every
single
copy of the book so you can pre-order it
tomorrow you actually don't get charged
I think until until the book actually
mails out which would be a couple months
from now but I am super psyched I have
given this book everything I've got it
is it'll be available for pre-sale
tomorrow of all the links will be at
Amazon and Barnes and Nobles and all the
usual the book places I don't want to
tease too much right now so tomorrow
I'll tell you a little bit more about
the book and what the process has been
like but I can tell you that I did a
deep dive into not only the things that
I talked about here but a lot of
personal stuff that I haven't talked
about that much and and just the process
of writing for everything you have heard
about what it's like to be a writer and
sitting in a room and locking myself in
a room which I did basically five days a
week for three hours from 9 a.m. to noon
pretty much every day for the last
couple months we eased up on the touring
and all that stuff so what else do I
want to tell ya yeah every single copy
that's the thing so every single copy by
the way the way one of the things that
the way the New York Times bestseller
works is that all your pre-sales go to
your first week debut sale numbers so
let's get this thing on the New York
Times bestseller I write about the New
York Times a little bit in the book too
and it would be fun to get on that New
York Times bestseller list wouldn't it
so yes okay so here's the deal
book tomorrow 3:30 Pacific 6:30 Eastern
I will sign every single copy oh and the
first thousand that we sell are gonna be
numbered so it'll be you know one one
thousand fifty seven 1998 one thousand
so those will be numbered but every
every book that I sell all day will be
then I go off the grid on Thursday from
August 1st to September 3rd I'm gonna
come back on the grid no phone no news
no television no nothing I'll tell you
guys what I'm doing when I get back we
have all new shows planned the entire
month so don't worry about that it's not
like we're just disappearing and not
giving you guys anything we actually
have a couple of great shows Brendan
O'Neill is back was absolutely fantastic
British thinker charlie Kirk is back we
have Jamie Metzl we do this great stuff
on on genetics and and cloning and
future
futurists and all sorts of cool stuff
and a really fun show with blank Harris
which is about video games and he wrote
a book called the console war it's about
Nintendo at Sega babies but anyway
tomorrow big livestream I'll tell you
more about everything I think I'm gonna
wrap this thing up this was just a
teaser oh and the reason we're doing a
teaser is because I'm just trying to
remind you guys to subscribe to click
the bell all of those things YouTube is
still messing with us
so subscribe that's I even have a note
here telling me to tell you to subscribe
people so click subscribe click the bell
you want a solid Bell that way you'll
get our videos and as you guys know I've
met with some of the higher-ups at
YouTube maybe I'll have some more info
on that in September oh and then I'll
also tell you that I have been teasing a
couple big announcements so I'll give
you one little teaser here so they'll be
when I get back on September 3rd there
will be another big career announcement
unrelated to the book but something big
that I'm doing with how this show gets
out there and where we put it and all
that kinda stuff that will also drop the
day I get back on September 11th the ink
has just dried on something so that's
one thing and then also in the last
couple months I started a tech company
I've met with some really great sort of
more libertarian classically liberal
minded thinkers in in Silicon Valley and
and tons of you guys have reached out to
me and I've had video chats and zoom
chats with the bajillion of you all
discussing ideas and I sort of come up
with something that I think can actually
solve a lot of this tech stuff and help
creators sort of control their content
and all that so we started a tech
company we got we got some VC I'm not
taking a dime of it and we are we are
building something really cool so
September 3rd I hope to have more info
on that we probably will it's being
built right now but we'll definitely
have this other big career thing and
yeah all right subscribe put that bell
on singular color or whatever it is
block it out right you want it to be
solid and and yeah big announcement
tomorrow I have a physical copy of the
book it's right there and we've got we
got great blurbs you might have heard of
the guy who's doing the foreword for
this book I'm super psyched as I said
penguin Random House they reached out to
me
we closed the deal I was actually in in
Oslo with Jordan Peterson so the odds
look show that we have on our channel I
found out about the book deal like five
minutes before that which was pretty
awesome so yeah I'll be able to show you
whose blurb in the book at least a
couple of the people that are blur
minute please forward it I'll tell you
all about it the title you'll see the
graphics we we've done something really
really really cool it's a whole other
thing than just just talking to you guys
like this but I'm super excited and yeah
there's there's a lot of good things
coming and then and then I disappear but
as I said all new shows come in so
alright that's it I was only supposed to
go for five minutes I went for seven
minutes and 14 seconds thank you guys
for watching tune in tomorrow and and
get ready first thousand copies you're
gonna get a numbered signed copy of Dave
Reubens book called I'll find out
tomorrow but everybody else I'm gonna
sign them all day long so I'm psyched
and alright we got a lot to do as we're
heading off the grid but a lot of good
stuff come and thank you everybody
and I'll see you tomorrow